Gayle King I probably told you down I'm
coming at you by the towing matter based
off of emotions me being angry a
question that's right overreacted Snoop
Dogg is burying the hatchet with Gayle
King sort of had a great different event
I was raised way back so I would like to
apologize to you probably for language
that I use calling the rapper took to
Instagram to publicly apologize to the
journalist after a video he posted last
week he went after Gayle for asking Lisa
Leslie if she thought Kobe Bryant's
legacy was quote complicated due to a
sexual assault charge that was dismissed
in 2003 I just never see have ever seen
him being the kind of person that would
be do something to violate a woman or be
aggressive than that way that's just not
the person that I know but Lisa you
wouldn't see it though as his friend you
wouldn't see it we expect more from you
Gayle don't you hang out with okra
why y'all attacking us we go people you
ain't coming after Harvey Weinstein
asking them dumb questions I get sick of
y'all I want to call you one is it okay
if I call him one funky dog hit how dare
you try to Taurus my homeboys reputation
Punk respect to family and back off
before we come get snoops reaction
didn't sit well with some including
former US National Security Advisor
Susan Rice she tweeted this quote this
is despicable Gayle King is one of the
most principled fair and tough
journalists alive snoop back the [ __ ]
you come for Gayle King you come against
an army you will lose and it won't be
pretty
the 48 year old took to Instagram to
attempt to clarify his initial
statements I'm a non-violent person when
I said what I said I spoke for the
people who felt like you know was there
disrespectful towards Kobe Bryant and
his family now with that being is
said what I looked like once some harm
to come to a 70 year old one
I was raised way better than that I
didn't want no harm to come at her and
didn't threaten her all I did was say
check it out you out of pocket according
to the wrapper today's apology was
inspired by his mother he captioned the
video quote how to talk with my mama
thank you mama
two wrongs don't make it right time to
heal at Gale King peace and love praying
for you and your family as well as
Vanessa and the kids I was just
expressing myself a lot of people look
up to you love me they appreciate me so
I want to let them know that anytime you
mess up it's okay to fix it so kind of
man episode you brought back in 2018
Snoop Dogg opened up to et about his
theory on how your foundation can
influence your relationships one thing I
noticed about people is that if you're
raised the right way you can connect
with anybody if you're raised on love
peace tranquility and harmony and get
along with anybody
[Music]